three two one
this engine will soon fly at Mach 5.
that's over three thousand miles per
hour
but the company that built it was on the
brink of failure just a few years ago
now they're closer than ever to getting
this Hypersonic Plane off the ground
this technology will change how goods
and people move around the planet it
effectively makes the world Regional New
York to Paris in 90 minutes LA to Tokyo
in about three hours if it works it will
change the landscape of both civilian
and Military Aviation forever and the
craziest part is that this technology
already Works we've been able to fly
faster than the speed of sound for
decades so why aren't all our planes
Hypersonic already what are the keys to
unlocking high-speed travel for real
this time the realities of physics and
economics have always gotten in the way
but this startup wants to solve this
problem for good this is the story of
hermius
[Music]
AJ piplica loved aircraft from a young
age specifically he loved the idea of
aircraft being used to transport people
loved the future like as a huge you know
sci-fi fan Star Trek and Star Wars we
are here only to help guide you into a
new era a thing that like always stuck
from me from just those universes that
that people imagine was like
transportation is such a major plot
point that nobody even thinks about it's
like oh we got these spaceships that
just fly all over the universe
it's like okay what's like the closest
thing to that in the world that we have
today it's like well airplanes Rockets
space stuff can I go find a book about
you know spacecraft space Frozen whatnot
I'm like well this uh looks nothing like
the Star Trek thing but still pretty
cool
after he graduated high school he went
to study aerospace engineering at
Georgia Tech
I really didn't know like what aerospace
engineering actually was I knew it's
like okay it's about airplanes right as
a grad student he worked at the NASA
Johnson Space Center in Houston
as an aerodynamicist in space isn't much
that you can do because it's a vacuum
right so it's like rocket engines or
re-entry and I ended up on the re-entry
side and that's how I kind of fell into
the hypersonics world AJ knew he wanted
to do something historic but he still
needed to find that first opportunity
and I got an email from Georgia Tech
saying Bill Nye the Science Guy is
coming to talk and I'm like Mom Dad I
need you to go and get his autograph for
me
so they went to this thing got his
autograph and uh the CEO of space Works
was like standing there in XM and my
parents started talking to him and they
came back to me later it was like hey
you should talk to this guy
so I just sent him a cold email was like
Hey like I'd love to learn a little bit
about what you do I'm interested in not
just engineering I'm interested in
business and that conversation turned
into a summer internship that turned
into a year-long internship that turned
into two years of part-time work during
grad school into a full-time job and
eventually into leading a subsidiary of
that company that company generation
orbit was in the hypersonics business in
August of 2015 generation orbit received
a U.S government grant to develop the
world's first commercially available
Hypersonic test bed that gave AJ more
Runway which he used to hire more staff
hired Glenn Glenn came from Blue Origins
I was thinking what there's a rocket
company in Atlanta that's crazy so I
reached out and said hey I know this is
a cold call love to talk and I
eventually just convinced them to give
me a job hired Skyler I just finished up
college and internships at the SpaceX it
was full-time really just AJ Glenn and
myself for a few months and then a
couple years later Mike the dissertation
that he wrote for his PhD was very close
to what we were doing AJ reached out on
LinkedIn their public profile was more
on small satellite launch kind of
combining a lot of the rocket stuff I've
been doing at SpaceX with my love of
hypersonics
so we worked together for about three
years bleeding in the trenches making
stuff happen
like ran systems engineering glenran
propulsion structures and Skyler ran
avionics software the four guys quickly
realized that they all shared a dream to
build a Hypersonic plane now in order to
understand hermius we have to get sharp
about a few key Concepts so I called up
Alex Hollings to explain kite for Sonic
is a word that we usually use to
describe objects that are traveling fast
enough for their speed to actually
affect the chemical makeup of the air
that they interact with and it tends to
happen at around Mach 5 and because of
that we use Mach 5 as sort of that
Baseline for what we consider to be
Hypersonic speed but it's not like a
physical barrier it's more just like a
concept
okay so at this point AJ and his team
had broken into the Aerospace industry
they were building cool stuff and
getting paid to do it but they wanted to
go bigger Hypersonic aircraft already
existed the X-15 reached the edge of
outer space in the 1960s and the U.S Air
Force awarded Boeing a contract to build
the x-20 a rocket-powered space plane
but none had ever carried civilian
passengers before they knew this
technology was ready for prime time you
could build a Mach 5 reusable vehicle
with today's technology if you frame the
problem correctly but in order to build
it they would need to Branch out on
their own and that's really what it took
to be to take the leap and say like okay
we see something much greater than what
we're doing here we're gonna quit our
relatively good paying jobs like and
we're going to leave and go start from
scratch we basically decided you know as
AJ usually likes to say jump off a cliff
and build an airplane on the way down
AJ Glenn Skyler and Mike gave themselves
six months to turn their idea into a
business we knew we wanted to build a
prototype engine it would be a rough
idea of how much it would cost us to do
that how long it would take us to do
that pseudo competitors I guess they're
really focused on other different
technologies that enable high speed but
don't use the same sort of fuels and
things that are readily available at
like airports and really from there it's
you know what are existing technologies
that we can plug together in an
interesting way so we have this like
very General Vision for what the long
term is okay like how do we get there
what's the road map and then like what
are the right incremental steps to take
from a technology perspective to get to
that roadmap and then what are the right
business steps to take so that the
business is scaling alongside so we can
actually raise money for this thing
these guys thought they had a solid
business plan so they applied to Y
combinator we didn't come from the
startup world we didn't know how to race
Venture Capital we didn't have a
connections like a network in Venture
Capital world so we're like we just got
to start with like the name brand and
see what happens everybody comes into a
pitch conversation around Hypersonic
airplanes with tons of opinions like
Concord failed why would this ever work
you're not Elon how are you going to do
this and it's like in five minutes how
do you get people educated enough and
trained to like that was tough
there are a lot of venture capital firms
that are not in good fits to something
like this for various reasons like you
know building airplanes is a capital
intensive thing and it's a very
different capex profile than than say a
B2B software as a service company YC was
interested they actually gave Hermes a
second interview which is really rare
but they ended up saying no AJ and his
co-founders were devastated it looked
like their dream was going to remain
Just a Dream but they decided to give it
one last shot
the beginning of 2019 we were making
some really really good progress with
the firm to the point where like we're
starting to have our first discussions
about a term sheet like we made it
further than we'd ever made it in the
past something weird started happening
and they started asking some pretty
strange questions like are you going to
give all the passengers concussions
going that fast and I'm like you you
confuse acceleration and velocity you
know
um and they're like well what about all
the fire like that's what engines do
they make fire
we had put together a board of advisors
so that was really good in validating
yeah you're like you guys are on the
right track this is really interesting
like if you're successful like you're
doing something that's important in the
middle of that meeting we're like
heading to dinner and I checked my email
and it's a note from The Firm that like
was like very very keen very like moving
forward they're like now we're out it's
like oh hey this is starting to get
close to that six month deadline
the pit of despair later that evening
right Verge on tears because what are we
going to do we only got a month how many
more meetings can we have I'm running
out of you know I'm starting to look for
jobs at this point they were about to
throw in the towel and even took a
personal day to clear their heads and
come up with slightly less serious
business ideas so Mike and I went one
way and we came up with this like we're
going to import homeowner barrico and
start like habon carts and Glenn and
Skyler went off and created this like
hot tub on a limousine at night idea
that was like Thursday of this week and
then Friday I get an email from Coastal
Adventure saying hey we'd love for you
to come in and talk to us about what
you're doing and it was like massive
High massive low and then another
massive High all in the span of a week
two weeks after that they were in a
meeting with vinod khosla himself what's
more he understood that Hermes was
trying to leverage existing technology
not create something entirely new most
people attempting something like this
are talking about multi-billion dollar
engine design and the decade done more
of huge uncertainty Hermes said a very
short path to proving the key risks out
and then going to Market in the National
Defense context I think the money hit
our bank account at like 7 P.M 6 10 p.m
on the last day of that six month clock
it was literally it like as close as you
can possibly cut it with the money from
their first funding round in the bank it
was officially time to start building
this thing
[Music]
every tech company wrestles with the
build versus buy trade-off and this was
a particularly hard problem for Hermes
they wanted to build an entirely new
kind of aircraft but still had to rely
on as many off-the-shelf parts as
possible to reduce risk to advance their
concept the team opted to modify an
existing jet engine we had to learn how
to you know operate the jet engine first
and then put our specific Hardware on
there it was really just kind of pedal
to the metal doing everything ourselves
and then built the team up to about
eight people
we showed in the seed round that we can
take a commercial jet engine pull off
its After Burner put our own After
Burner on and run it way higher speeds
than it's designed for
in October 2020 Hermes raised a 16
million series a round the company's
Next Step was even bigger take the
subscale engine that we did build a full
scale version of it called Chimera
Chimera is what's called a turbine-based
combined cycle engine which means it's
basically a hybrid between a turbo jet
and a Ramjet let's break down the
difference between a traditional jet
engine and a Ram Jet your typical jet
engine uses compressed air and fuel to
generate High Velocity exhaust it can
increase power slowly to allow for
takeoff and Landing Ram jets are
different though they have no moving
parts and instead rely on forward motion
to compress air for combustion this
means that the external boost to start
working which is why they're usually
launched from planes or Rockets
Hermes combined these two technologies
to allow the engine to take off from a
standstill and then transition to Ramjet
power once the aircraft is traveling
fast enough so it's both a jet engine
and a Ram Jet hence the name Chimera how
we transition from a turbojet engine at
low speed to a Ramjet engine at high
speed that's something that's never been
done in flight
the team used modern manufacturing
techniques like 3D printing to
accelerate development and it worked
they developed the Chimera engine in
just over a year but making the engine
was only half the battle then they had
to go prove that it worked there's only
one wind tunnel in the United States
that I'm aware of that can support
Hypersonic speeds it's a NASA wind
tunnel with hypersonic tests in the
United States we've done something like
22 and 10 years and that's just not fast
enough to be able to feel this
technology in the kind of volume that we
want to feel that startups are always a
Race Against Time and the Hermes team
had to move fast we sent a contract with
Notre Dame's turbo Machinery laboratory
so we ship it up there start doing our
testing up there and fortunately the
first test was a huge success and proved
that the hybrid concept worked being
able to show that was a pretty
substantial de-risk and like hey this
technology could work so that unlocked
the series be with led by Sam Altman and
with some participation from some other
folks founder spine what series B
allowed us to do is really start putting
the you know pushing the throttle all
forward for quarter horse
quarter horse is hermes's first airplane
and while that prototype couldn't fly
there was a lot it could do
so what goal do we set at hydrosonics
today
they celebrate these but wobble human
Transportation Network
our goal is to complete that challenge
the five passengers across oceans
Hypersonic speeds before this young
decade is out
we're thinking what's the most audacious
thing that we could do kind of unveil
our product what if we had an aircraft
unveil which everybody has an aircraft
unveil right usually it's a styrofoam
model and you pull it away and then it's
like Ugh congratulations you made
something pretty we wanted to do more we
want to actually fire an engine in there
so if everyone could please take the
headsets this is definitely something
you're going to want to see and feel
I can't tell you how many trials and
tribulations just that effort had with
that video that everybody's seen of just
like oh wow here's quarter horse wow
we're a little bit ahead of where you
think we are
their quarter horse prototype was a big
achievement and it brought them a step
closer to realizing their Grand Vision
but the journey toward a fully
functional aircraft was still far from
over all of our first aircraft are
remotely piloted when they're remotely
piloted you know that's a pretty well
solved problem at this point what is not
as well solved is how fast we have to
take off and land so you can't have big
wings you want things that are low drag
to be able to push that speed up and up
and up and that's really the opposite of
what you want when you're Landing so
being able to thread that needle is
where we're kind of focused but this is
where things get a little tricky
foreign
the real challenge is building the
machine that builds the machine it's not
enough to build one plane they need to
scale their operations so they can
efficiently produce tons of these
aircraft our initial tale of quarter
horse is really the one where we're
testing out the team coming together
working with the manufacturing team
integrated engine and really test every
subsystem that we have and bring as many
learnings as possible to the left we
can't lose sight that we need to build
Hardware we need to go test so we need
to go fly it and then iterate and really
change the way that we as a country are
designing these types of aircraft we've
done that with rockets we've figured out
how to do that but we haven't done that
yet with aircraft putting out a new
aircraft on less than a year Cadence
that's I think the level of iteration
that's going to be required to actually
solve these problems this rapid
iteration is massively resource
intensive but turbocharges new
development right now the team sees
quarter horse as mostly a prototype but
the next step is where they enter the
big leagues these renders are of Dark
Horse their next generation of
hypersonic aircraft although the team
has the goal of revolutionizing
Passenger travel this aircraft has
massive military potential and this is
where we need to talk about Hypersonic
weapons
[Music]
foreign
weapons offer massive advantages in
terms of speed maneuverability because
of the name people always focus on how
fast the weapons travel but we've had
icbms for decades and those re-enter the
atmosphere at Hypersonic speeds what's
crucial about Hypersonic weapons is that
they can fly closer to the Earth this
means they hide below the Horizon
reducing the time before radar can
detect them and making them much harder
to shoot down and America's two biggest
Rivals are investing heavily in
Hypersonic technology cyanide is
Fielding Hypersonic anti-ship weapons
that they want to use to prevent
American aircraft carriers primarily
from being able to come within a
thousand miles of Chinese Shores it's an
area defense approach Russia is trying
to maintain their role as the second
largest armed supplier in the world and
a big part of that is advancing The
Narrative of having very modern weapons
that people will want to pay top dollar
for the United States and lots of other
countries have developed air launched
ballistic missiles but they don't use
them because there's no way as a
Defender to discern between an inbound
ballistic missile with a nuclear warhead
on board and one without I think the
first application we'd see for a
platform like Dark Horse at hermius
would be ISR intelligence surveillance
and reconnaissance there's kind of two
key attributes to Dark Horse number one
is responsivus which is flying very fast
over long distances and in the Pacific
Theater that's what that theater is
characterized by long distances and then
the other piece is taking action in
contested environments so like can you
be survivable enough to not get shot
down the United States and most other
well-developed militaries in the world
are trying to network everything that's
where Hypersonic aircraft could either
fill that rule or they could rapidly
deploy Communications nodes reusable
Hypersonic aircraft would end the
Hypersonic arms race winning this arms
race wouldn't stop China and Russia from
continuing to invest in their own
military capability but it would provide
the US and its allies with a strong
deterrent and deterrence is the best
tool we have to prevent Wars from
breaking out
Hermes had proved the feasibility of
their core technology but at the same
time they were edging closer to the
Valley of Death Valley of Death it's
like the period of time from after you
got a prototype or a demonstration
before you get production and you know
it's called the Valley of Death because
that's sort of that window where most
companies die that's that two to three
year Spa where the department is kind of
chipping through their internal
government processes you know companies
need to continue to show revenue and
growth and most companies can't afford
to kind of chip through that Valley of
Death every defense tech company needs
to find a way to get through the valley
of death anderol was a great example of
how to solve that problem but not all
defense tech companies make it through
so you have to phase your Milestones
correctly and you have to get the
customer to build a bridge across that
like Valley of Death with a longer term
contract even if it's if it's not a
procurement contract an r d contract
that's of a large enough scale to like
fund the company keep it going and using
Venture Capital to fund growth AJ and
his co-founder started Hermes because
they believed that the technology was
ready that they could attract private
capital and that the US government might
invest in hypersonics if Hermes was
going to cross the Valley of Death all
those things had to come true when
you're doing this really hard deep Tech
problem you can't just go straight to
the finish line and try and build the
Hypersonic aircraft that has ISR
capabilities and weapons on board and
can defeat China like like that's way
too tall of an order there's just too
many unknowns it's too too Capital
intensive and there's way too much risk
so instead they basically raise money
and then they build an engine then they
go and test it and then they get a
contract with government which proves
revenue or like demand and then they go
and raise more so their first contract I
believe was to evaluate the viability of
a Hypersonic Air Force One there was no
way that they were going to promise to
build and Hypersonic Air Force One but
the fact that they were still able to
get a contract and actually
get some response from the government
and get some get some you know buy-in
that hey we will actually give you money
there's now revenue on the books just to
deliver kind of just a report and some
data so if you come in with an idea
you have a higher burden to prove the
utility of that so a lot of what we're
doing right now is like tell a story to
the apartments like hey even if I don't
deliver an aircraft at the end of the
day if I study and mature these subsets
of Technologies you're still getting
your money's worth because these are
problems that America needs to solve so
getting that on contract has a huge
benefit for us of like having stable
Revenue getting real buy-in from the
department and then like the ability to
Anchor Milestones with the government to
build that confidence and comfort so
that we can go build the mission the
mission critical vehicle but in order to
do that and this is one of the
conversations we have but the government
is like you guys have to continue to
show up as we succeed so that we can ask
more of our investors the end goal is to
win what's called a program of record
this is when the government has
allocated ongoing funding across many
years to really put a new piece of
technology into use
Hypersonic aircraft is such a novel
concept for the dod that there isn't
anybody who owns it and so now we're
even just trying to help the department
think about who should own this because
before you get to a programmable records
you have somebody to own it feed it care
for it advocate for it so there's all
these sort of like sub steps of dealing
with the world's largest bureaucracy
that come well before a program record I
certainly want to get us to a program
record that's our end-all be-all even if
you build the world's greatest piece of
technology that in of itself doesn't
guarantee you anything
the surface area that you have to cover
to make a sale of like a multi-hundred
million dollar contract to the dod is
massive you have to work with the end
users the war Fighters because they're
the ones that send the demand signal so
you need that important then you need
the acquisition community on board the
folks are actually going to make the
money decisions of like all right are we
going to prioritize this or this and
then you need Congress on board they're
the final say on the budget like yes the
Air Force gets to say what they want and
the president gets to say what what he
or she wants but Congress is the final
say on what what actually gets funded
it's something that very few companies
and very few people have done
successfully as far as like Venture back
companies that have done it the only
ones that have done it have had
billionaire Founders that have been able
to like give the company enough runway
in time to be successful in getting to a
large scale defense program there's a
tension between the Department of
Defense and Industry on where did that
idea originate an idea that comes from
the outside in is going to get treated
far more hostily than an idea that comes
from the inside out and if you think
about the term defense contractor that's
because as historically the defense
department contracted somebody to build
them something so they they were the
expert on what was needed when you're a
defense program it's really important to
have public support otherwise you end up
like the B1 bomber in 1977 where the
public was asking why are we doing this
and that ended up canceling the program
so if you can get the public excited
then it's a lot easier to get the
defense department to pay you AJ and his
co-founders had come a long way from
trying to import homeown America but
they were still so much farther to go
[Music]
seeing this Resurgence of interest in
hypersonics at the defense level and I
think that is more driven by some
geopolitical events where hey like now
there's this re-interest in hypersonics
that's really unlocking the type of
technology that we want to be developing
that serves a great purpose on the
defense side but also kind of leads into
like what that commercial vision is
After Dark Horse Hermes is planning to
build Halcyon a commercial aircraft that
can fly 20 people from New York to Paris
in 90 minutes how Airlines differentiate
their products is through comfort and
luxury there are way better ways to
spend extra resources that are going to
those things that can produce more for a
broader scope of people
and that comes down to speed Halcyon has
the potential to transform travel trade
and diplomacy and if it did then it
would totally transform the way we live
our lives while we talk about using
resources instead of for comfort
to put them towards speed and in this
time and when you do that at a global
scale you unlock that latent potential
of humanity in both the social and
economic sense an economic sense we
speed up the World by 5X
that will drive Global GDP growth two
and a half percent a year that's four
trillion dollars a year AJ piplica and
his co-founder started Hermes because
they wanted to create the biggest
paradigm shift in aviation for more than
50 years Hypersonic missiles very likely
won't change the world Hypersonic
Aviation very likely will in order for
their dream to become a reality three
things needed to come true the
technology needed to be feasible they
had to attract private capital and they
had to successfully sell the US
government to avoid the value of death
and in the process they might just have
given the US and its allies a big
advantage in the Hypersonic arms race so
far they've succeeded but there's still
a long way to go there's a question that
comes up more often than any other
why are you doing this why did you
choose to do this versus anything else
that you could do the answer to that
question is the massive impact that not
just this technology but the products
and services that come after it the
defense applications that can help
prevent a large-scale geopolitical
conflict
these things will have a massive
sustainable positive impact not just on
the people in this room but for the
entire human race and there are not many
things that you can spend your time
doing that you can say that about to
learn about another company that's using
advanced technology to help the United
States restore the global balance of
power just watch this video next thanks
a lot
foreign